this video is about the
most important question
types that you can use in your questionnaires we will
discuss what the
question types have to pay attention to and how you
evaluate them this is our second video
on the subject of questionnaires if
you like you can use the content in our
read the book you will find the link in
the video description we will start with
a brief overview what are the
most important question types and which
ones we will go into in this video there
are open questions questions with a
simple answer questions with
multiple answers questions with simple
answer in tables or matrix form
ask multiple answers inter press
inform and the so-called semantic
differential to each question type
we will now briefly go into it and discuss it
using an example we start
with the simple question type of the open
question here simply asks a question
and  gives the respondents the
opportunity to answer without any restrictions  place
to give, for example what job
do you do or what is your favorite book of
course you can also ask
questions that can be answered in more detail
, for example do you have further
feedback on the product or what could be
improved in online teaching then there
are still open questions  you only
ask about moravian values, for
example your age or monthly
net income if you
ask about a numerical value the questions can of
course be used very well in the context of
quantitative research,
but make sure that you use the open
questions with a text answer very
sparingly  should work around why
no uniform
answers are given for open questions and this makes the
quantitative evaluation of the questions very
difficult, so you are always aware
that if you ask an open question
you can get a large number of different
answers, let's take a look
at the question  she still
far  res feedback on the product the
first person answered for example
the product is great the
second the packaging is too big for
me the third I like the color and so
on and so forth if you
want to answer these questions you have to go
through each individual answer and  assign the
content to proven or
categories another case
is of course if you now ask for the
holder here each person interviewed gives
a number we as the first and
with these answers you can
continue working or carry out analyzes
so we now come to the next question
topics  the question with a simple answer
questions becomes simple answer are
probably the most frequently used
question types with this question type you can
ask, for example, how satisfied
are you with the online teaching and you
specify the possible answers
these can then be as follows very
satisfied he  satisfied he dissatisfied
very dissatisfied the respondents can d  a
tick only one of the answer options another example would be what
is your favorite video streaming
service in this case you could
specify the following answer
options netflix amazon prime disney plus and
apple tv now with simple
answers there is the option to add an
additional open text field
this will  then other mentioned
with this option,
the respondents can then
freely enter another option the nice
thing about asking questions with a simple answer is
that you get the results in a very
clean form and
you can use them very easily to answer your
research question or
hypotheses if you  at the
end of your online survey
you have exported the results in each
row a person interviewed with the
respective answer the answer can only have
one of the four values or be inval
d if the person has n
t answered the question, for e
ample, the ers  th person
answered rather satisfied, the
second person rather dissatisfied and so
on and so forth you can
then have the
results displayed in a frequency table, for example, in
the frequency stable you can then see
how often each answer occurred.
Another possibility is the
results  in a bar
chart then the
height of the bar indicates the respective
frequency very similar to the question with a
single answer is the question with
multiple answers the only difference
is that in
this case the respondents can not just tick one
answer but several  a
question could be, for example, when
do you use product xy
the possible answers in
this case can be morning noon
evening and at night as I said in this
case it is possible to tick several answers,
for example morning and
evening another example is the
question which video streaming service you
use  [ __ ]  Here you can also
tick several options, just
like with the simple selection, there is of
course also
the possibility to add an open text field with the
multiple selection. This is very
important when evaluating questions. It is very important to note that each
answer option is treated as a single
question  will you use the
product in the morning yes or no do
you use the product at noon yes or no and
so on and so forth when you export the
results of a survey to excel
you will
not see one variable band you will use
product xy but you will see four
variables or columns one column for
morning one for midday one for evening
and one for night in this case
means 1 yes and no so the first
person does not use the product in the
morning but at noon in the evening or at night
for this reason it is important that you
choose the question type  multiple selection only
if you really want it
several answer options are
possible otherwise always select a question with a simple
answer let's take a look
at the following example your question
is how satisfied are you with the
online blankness only one
answer option should be selected by the respondents
let's assume you
look like an unsuitable type  simply
answer selected but multiple
answers in this case you will
not get your data in this beautiful form
but each answer
option is a column so that you
can still answer the question you must
first add a new column
and know how to create this variable
you now display the results of a question
with multiple choices one
possibility is also to know how often
the answer occurred in the morning at noon in the evening and
at night here you can see
what percentage that results in and here
you can see what percentage of cases this
corresponds to 53.85 of  person have
indicated that si  e use the
product you can of
course also see whether
there is a connection, e.g. whether people
who use the product in the morning have also
shortened it there is this product
have use it so we now come to
the questions with simple answers in
table form here you could  For
example, ask how satisfied are you
with product xy in terms of design,
operation, customer support and price on
a scale from very satisfied are very
dissatisfied in this
case only one answer can be given in each row
so there are
four questions with  simple answer of this
question is used if you
want to create a legal one watch
my video on the delicious scale here if
you explode the results of a survey in excel
or data tab you will see that
a new variable has been created for each question
, so one is created
variable or column for design service
customer support and a column for price
at each  In the series it is
again a questioned person. Now you can
display how often the
respective characteristic occurs,
i.e. what frequencies there are. You can also display
the mean value and the median.
Of course, you have to be careful with the interpretation of the mean value with
coordinates, similar to
the simple answer in tabular form is
the multiple answer in tabular form the
only difference is that, as the
name suggests, multiple answers are possible with this type of question
. An
example would be the question when do
you use which product, a respondent could
then state that they use the product a
in the morning and  used in the evening here
i would like to point out that in
very few cases it happens that you
really need a multiple answer
the evaluation of such question
types turns out to be quite tedious because each
individual answer option is regarded as a new
variable or individual
question if you use the
exported results to excel or data tab it
looks like this you have product a
with morning noon evening and night
then comes product b with morning noon
evening and night and so on and
so forth in the results then 1 means
that the point was ticked and  0
means that the point was not ticked
and this brings us to the last
question type of the linear scale also called
semantic or social here
you can ask how strongly the
respondents connect with a certain
characteristic an example would be
the question what is important to them on vacation
relaxation or experience cheap
price and quality
package tour or individual
tour we have now discussed all the important questions that you can use in your questions if you just want to create an online survey please have a
look at the data tab there you
can easily do it in the next
video  it goes on with the lex
koller I hope the video has  you
like it and we'll see each other again soon